there is a there is some three
three thousand guy who
wants to play with an increment
so yeah i'll probably play this one and
um
and then we'll call today
let's play something fancy let's play
the bank of gambit maybe
okay let's play it with e6
and yeah this bishop p7 is kind of
not completely pointless
yeah then i guess you cancel
bishop c4 i think this was possible as
well
maybe we just take on d5 here
there is also a fancy idea of rook takes
a6 in many lines but
uh the problem is not
is not bishop takes a six but it is you
know sometimes
black will feel feel bad after just
random move
there is not much for the rook to do
there
okay so now saying that i will
i'm tempted by playing rook takes a6
but i think i have to take with the
bishop which is a bit sad
and check and queen takes a6 looks
looks logical
he hasn't castle yet which makes it um
which makes it a bit uncomfortable for
white to play
but yeah looks good for white all in all
the other hand it's you know it might
look good but you have to play moves
he plays bishop c3 which is uh very very
logical
does he want to castle long at some
point
it's hard to believe to be honest
okay so how should we play this
maybe just rookie bishop f8 like let him
play moves
by the way g7 is sort of hanging here
okay let's go to d then
place knight f4 okay
so now we can um yeah we have moves we
can even play knight before
you can also play bishop f8 simply
okay so let's say bishop of fate
he probably just wants to play queen d3
and castle then
making sure he's never worse
yeah this is not kind of kind of an
opening queue you should play against a
strong player on the other hand i played
it against nakamura
so it's not that i don't think he's a
good player
what i like is that with a bishop on a
fade there is not much to blunder
like we prevented all the knight h5
stuff
yeah he simply plays a3 literally asking
for
knight before and some of the lines
wow h3 is a bit surprising this this
basically means he
he does not really know what to do he's
probably
trying to prepare some castling long or
um
yeah or maybe ruby one
we can play knight before takes takes a4
and then something like d2c8
shouldn't be too good shouldn't be too
bad either
yeah on the other hand like whatever we
play queer windows 3 still
there so yeah i mean in general
we have to do something unfortunately
okay we cannot
wait forever let's go night before b
should be four c before a4 and then
something like b3 maybe
or rook d two c eight
here we have q industry you know in all
of those lines
but yeah i mean black should probably
hold there
he keeps uh thinking what makes me feel
nervous
like what else do you consider
no there's nothing company takes
three okay this is basically a draw for
um
yeah okay i have to have to go for it
i mean he probably wants to to play this
little
claiming that it is not exactly a draw
[Music]
okay let's say bishop d6
yeah what i'm doing is uh is actually
strange yeah i blundered the palm
actually
can i take on h2 there
no no
yeah somehow i was not ready for playing
this 4 against 4
now i have to work
and bishop d8
d5
yeah then he will get um
knight beat or this way and he can play
forever
this is not exactly what you want from
the banter blitz
i must say
okay
e4 is a bit of relief i mean the move is
completely fine but at least he
he's not trying to wait for 50 moves to
improve
and maybe check i guess we
simply trade
and then we start waiting somehow
i mean whenever he goes too far with the
kings there is b1
okay then we have a check
yeah i can probably even play f6
yeah i guess i can
take stakes makes it a bit easier
keep waiting
waiting
i mean i could have played g5 probably
but i don't want to do such thing
down to like one second so i'll just
i'll just prefer to
uh to wait and gain some time
nine g2 okay king of five maybe
knight is three maybe king of six one
and bishop a7
maybe king is six
king six was not brilliant by the way
i'm actually about to let him
like let him get exactly what he's
trying to get
which is still a draw
but less comfortable draw i would say
maybe i could have taken but once again
with five seconds
you don't want to do such thing
he's actually a short on time now as
[Music]
well
allows b7 okay go back
bishop d4 i think we had this already
bishop c3 maybe
brings knight to f1 okay
and g4 g4 is a relief
now it has to be even more simple
i think we pretty much wait whatever
happens
okay king maybe f6
bishop to c7 there is not much going on
here
okay maybe we can get five k6
we should d8 now we wait this way
okay
okay king f7
you got this but this is still you know
very drawish
okay whatever
is there a 50 move rule here
he he's playing a bit like in any house
are in to be honest
he sort of plays like a chicken
then he gets this you know that draw
with a little chance and then he
he tries to place it forever pretending
he's better okay